[Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  who's enjoying this relaxing view here  in Montana  do you think the water down there is  cold  it's a beautiful day here in Montana  Montana's in the United States yes you  can swim in the lake there's a beach  here we're right outside of Bozeman  Montana in Hyalite Canyon there is a  beach right on this Lake now we're at  the water is a little bit cool but the  temperatures very hot it's pop its  popular but not overly crowded which  beauty you like best this one or this  one thank you for watching  [Music]  [Music]  I'm not sure what types of fish are in  this lake but I've been seeing some jump  there are no sharks in this lake  we are in highlight Canyon Montana this  is in Montana United States  I hope everybody had a relaxing journey  here in highlight Canyon Montana thanks  for watching